there are a few types of pairs of angles
that the competitive exams test you with
two of them are complementary and
supplementary the name sound fancy but
the concept is simple two angles are
complementary if the sum of the measures
is 90 degrees and two angles will be
supplementary if the sum of the measures
will 180 degrees yes that's how simple
it is look at these two angles 35 plus
55 is 90 so yes they are complementary
angles if the sum of two angles is 90
degrees then they are complementary
look at this figure and try to name the
two complementary angles here we are
given that angle ABC is a right angle
which means it measures 90 degrees it
means the sum of these two angles will
surely be 90 degrees so angle abd and
angle DBC will be complementary angles
remember if the sum is 90 degrees then
angles are complementary here's another
pair of angles 120 plus 60 is 180
degrees which makes them supplementary
and this figure in which line MP is a
straight line also has supplementary
angles angle MN O and angle o and P are
supplementary notice that these two
angles are supplementary as well as
adjacent adjacent angles which are
supplementary formed something called a
linear pair the two adjacent angles form
a line and now let's move on to the last
type for angles are formed when two
lines intersect one two three and four
in this figure angle 1 and angle 3 are
vertically opposite angles they are
formed when two lines intersect each
other
they are opposite each other and have
the same vertex with the same logic
angle 2 and angle 4 are also vertically
opposite angles both these pairs are
called vertically opposite angles and
vertically opposite angles are always
equal in this case angle 1 will be equal
to angle 3 and the measure of angle 2
will be equal to that of angle 4 it
doesn't matter how the lines are moved
vertically opposite angles are always
equal